(Skype ringing)
- Hey.
- Is that one of those fancy
coffee cups that stays warm?
- It heats it from the bottom.
- [Johnny] That's my friend Cleo
who is a newly independent journalist
making stuff on YouTube.
- An I'm gonna call it "Huge, if true."
- There aren't a lot of
journalists/YouTubers out there,
and now that there's another one,
I'm gonna ask for her help.
Okay, so I wanna show you a map.
Do you see this map?
- Yes.
- [Johnny] This is the Congo.
It's this giant country in Central Africa
that used to be called Zaire.
And what's crazy about this
that I've never seen before is
if you map all of the mines in Congo,
it looks like this.
- Wow.
- [Johnny] And all of
these are the cobalt mines.
- Cobalt?
- [Johnny] Cobalt.
Yes, cobalt, it's a thing
that used to not be important at all
but it's now very important
and that's what I'm sort
of fixating on right here.
These are cobalt mines
and 15 of them are run by China.
- I know where this is going.
- But wait, this isn't another
just China moves into Africa story.
I've made a video on that.
This story feels bigger,
like we're going through some shift
in how we make and use energy.
- We are going to transition
this country into the future.
- Which means reusing new materials,
new materials like cobalt.
So the question is,
who's gonna control these
new valuable minerals
in the future
and how will they use that control?
- Oh, because cobalt is
in electric car batteries
and a bunch of other stuff?
- Yes, bingo, electric car batteries,
the thing that everyone
is racing to figure out
and make more of.
- I mean, look at this chart
of the demand for EVs over time,
like it's just exploding.
So the reason I'm showing you all of this
is because you're a technology person,
you think about this stuff,
and you tend to have a more
sort of optimistic view
than I do on a lot of the future,
and I kind of want that perspective here.
Because what I see here
is just another instance
of a big superpower, China,
racing into an underdeveloped
country to steal its resources
so that it can control the supply chain.
And, to be honest,
I thought the clean energy
revolution would look,
I don't know, different,
different than this.
(baby crying)
I wasn't expecting this.
- I really do think that it can.
I think that there's a world
in which there's a green energy revolution
that doesn't look like the same old story
of all the other fossil fuels and minerals
that we've mined before.
I don't think it's gonna be easy
but I think there are ways to pull it off.
- I like her optimism.
- Well, let's get into it.
I wanna show you what I've
learned here on cobalt
'cause I've sort of
been down a rabbit hole
on the cobalt China situation.
And then I want to have a discussion
about what this means
for the future of energy.
- Let's do it.
- [Reporter] The children
were mining cobalt
in the Democratic
Republic of Congo, or DRC.
- [Reporter] Cobalt is one of the world's
most coveted resources.
Its value has nearly
tripled over the past year.
- [Reporter] This most
precious of minerals
is often extracted and sorted by tiny-
- [Reporter] The Chinese traders
here bought all the cobalt
and sold it mainly to one Chinese company.
- Okay, hold on one second,
I need to thank today's
sponsor who is NordVPN.
A VPN is a tool that allows
you to connect to the internet
but not through the place that you're at,
you can do it through a different country.
Why would you want to do this?
Well, I use NordVPN when I'm traveling,
when I'm in different countries
and I want my internet connection
to route through the United States
so that my email and all my logins
don't think I'm someone
from a different country
trying to log in to my stuff.
But I also use it when
I'm in the United States
and wanna log in via other countries
so I can access way more content,
way more stuff that I don't
have access to in the US
but I do if I connect through Britain.
NordVPN is a very easy, smooth, quick way
of doing all of this.
Nord also has a major focus
on security and encryption
so that your internet
connection is always secure.
Oh, and it doesn't cost very much money.
There's a link in my description,
it's NordVPN.com/JohnnyHarris.
Clicking that link supports this channel
but it also gets you an exclusive deal.
Oh, and if you decide that
it's not useful to you
for any reason,
within 30 days you can get
all of your money back.
So go try it out,
go see if this can expand
your entertainment options,
help you connect to the internet
more securely, et cetera.
Thank you, NordVPN, for
sponsoring this video.
Let's get back to it.
So, first let's understand what cobalt is.
It's this blue mineral that's
become really important
in the past few years.
I mean, just look at the
price of cobalt since 2010.
It's like popped off
in these last few years
because of one thing.
- [Reporter] Electric cars
are expected to double
the world's demand for
cobalt by the year 2025.
- I wanna continue to
explain cobalt and China
and all of that,
but first we have to understand the DRC,
the Democratic Republic of the Congo.
This massive country
in the middle of Africa
that honestly should be
one of the richest countries on Earth
because it is sitting on top
of so many valuable resources.
Unfortunately, this is a place
that for centuries has not been able
to actually take advantage of this wealth
because it has been pillaged by outsiders.
Whether that's the people
being literally stolen
and shipped across the
Atlantic as forced labor,
or this brutal Belgian king who came in
and forced the Congolese people to work,
to harvest rubber,
or more recently the blood diamond rush.
I mean, this place has
been pillaged for years
because of its resources.
So, here we are in 2022.
The new hot commodity
is not rubber or diamonds, it's cobalt,
this blue mineral that used to be
just for making ceramics turn blue,
that's what it was used before,
but now it has a really useful purpose
in the growing world of electric vehicles.
- [Reporter] Electric vehicles.
- A lot of people love Tesla.
- [Reporter] This is
the EV sales forecast.
- Electric vehicles are the future.
- So, I know something
about how electric car batteries are made.
I kind of know the
things that go into them.
How did a substance
that made ceramics blue
end up being so important
to electric car batteries?
- [Johnny] Well, at first,
lithium is the main ingredient
and that was the most important.
But as more and more car companies
are trying to make their cars
go longer and further without exploding,
cobalt is this amazing material
that helps regulate the heat
and volatility of an EV.
- So cobalt is super important
for electric cars to be
able to go long distances
without needing to recharge or exploding?
- Absolutely, we're in this phase
where every car company is competing
on these sort of nuanced
marginal improvements,
like my car can go 400
kilometers, mine can go 410,
and so cobalt is becoming
more and more important
for these long range features
that are becoming important
in this cut-throat competition.
It turns out that the Congo
has 70% of the world's cobalt.
I'm not kidding when I say this
place is like resource rich.
- You're rich.
- So this is becoming
a bigger and bigger issue,
but guess who read the tea
leaves like 20 years ago
and started investing in
cobalt mines in the Congo?
- China.
Yes, obviously. China.
- [Reporter] The Democratic
Republic of Congo
struck a big deal with Beijing.
- [Reporter] Chinese traders
here bought all the cobalt
and sold it mainly to one Chinese company.
- This is where I start to get pessimistic
about the whole green energy revolution,
and let me tell you why.
I made this video a while back
about how China has
been rushing into Africa
to build up a bunch of infrastructure
and to win the hearts of African nations,
but also to kind of assert
control and leverage over them.
But as a part of all of this
Chinese investment in Africa,
China has been pouring
loads of money into mines,
specifically focusing on the DRC
where all these minerals are.
And again, this is like the early 2000s.
They set up all of these mines
and started mining and processing cobalt.
- If you look at a chart of EV demand,
it goes way up in the 2000s.
How did they know,
like, why would China show
up and start mining cobalt
if it wasn't particularly valuable yet?
- Yeah, and that's a
really important question,
and the answer just sort of blew my mind.
The first one is easy,
which is that cobalt became
useful for other things,
like cellphone batteries
and things like that,
so there already was
some decent demand there.
But it's also because of
how China's economy works.
Because China is a communist country
where the state and the
economy are intertwined,
they have different incentives
than the capitalist West.
Like, in our economy,
we have independent corporations
who focus on delivering short-term
profits to shareholders.
In China, they can take longterm bets.
They can say, like, in 20 years
we think that this is
gonna be really valuable
so we're gonna pour
tons of money into this
because we don't need to
deliver profits next quarter,
we can deliver profits in 20 years.
So it gives them this unique
ability to make big bets
that could potentially be huge,
and in this case it was
the absolute best bet
they could have made.
- We hit the jackpot here!
- So all of this explains
why China controls 15
out of the 19 cobalt mines in the DRC.
- Okay, so you got electric
vehicles demand going up,
cobalt is necessary for electric vehicles,
and then you've got China
with their foresight
buying up all of these mines in the Congo
to control the supply of cobalt
which we're gonna need for EVs.
- Yes, that is exactly right.
And this gets into the strategy
and the geopolitics of all of this.
There's this one quote
from an expert that Politico interviewed.
He says that "China is not
processing all of that cobalt
"to export it to the United States
"to support your electric
vehicle revolution.
"They're gonna make cheap cars themselves
"and the best that you can hope for
"is that they'll export
those cheap cars to you."
Like, it's just so clear
that they're doing this
to control what they see as
a massive burgeoning market
that they wanna have a corner
on, and they're doing it.
And here we go with why
I feel so disappointed
as I learn about all of this.
Here you have China racing to
control this valuable mineral
so that they can have leverage and power
as the world transitions
to cleaner energy.
Oh, and not to mention
that as China shows up
and does all of this cobalt mining,
you'll see no regard for worker safety,
you'll see super dangerous mines,
you'll see children
doing back-breaking work,
you have people routinely
dying on the job.
And perhaps the biggest
contradiction of all
is that this is a finite
resource once again.
Oh, and the process of mining
and refining this stuff
is the same old story of
deforestation, polluted rivers,
and just general exploitation.
I mean, I thought the
sustainable green revolution
was going to be like
clean and just for people.
I thought electric cars
would actually mean
a cleaner way of doing business,
like a cleaner future.
But instead we're seeing the
same old Earth destroying
great power resource race
that got us here in the first place.
- You good?
- Yeah, my rant is over,
I'm sorry, this has
gotten me really worked up
and I'm ready to chill out now.
- You need to chill.
- When I used to imagine
a clean energy future,
I had this image in my head, right,
of that moment in every
sci-fi where they go, like,
"Once we lived in harmony."
♪ People lived in harmony ♪
- And there's Wakanda and
there's that one Chobani ad
where everyone is using technology
and living in a beautiful farm.
Record scratch, freeze frame,
here we are in the real world
where right now it totally is
the same old story of exploitation
and harm to the environment
in different ways
and harm to people.
I think one thing that's
important to realize
is that when we talk
about a cleaner future
we're specifically talking about less CO2,
and so though it conjures up
all of these images of
clean in other ways,
it's on us to do that also.
There's nothing about the technology
that inherently will bring that about.
- Oh dear, what can we do?
- We have a few things that we can do.
The first is we can change
the kinds of batteries
that we're using.
There's a lot of development
in new kinds of batteries,
one of them is a lithium-iron battery,
not a lithium-ion battery,
there's an extra R in there.
And that battery uses
different kinds of minerals,
it doesn't use any cobalt.
That might help this specific example
but the reality is that
most of these minerals
have their own stories of exploitation,
so it's not...
- It's not great.
- So here's where I start
to feel pretty optimistic.
There's a big difference between
fossil fuels and minerals.
You're right that the difference
between electric vehicles
and gas combustion vehicles
is that one uses fossil fuels
and the other we're swapping
up fossil fuels for minerals,
but there's a big difference
between fossil fuels and minerals,
namely fossil fuels are being incinerated
every time that we drive.
If we're using more
minerals to power our cars,
we also have the opportunity
to get a lot better at recycling.
This shows how much we already recycle.
This is end-of-life recycling
rates for select metals
in electric car batteries.
- [Johnny] Hm, oh, so
we're already recycling
a lot of these materials,
including cobalt,
like it's almost 40%.
- Yes, and the other thing
to keep in mind here is
you don't need to recycle
these minerals and metals
in cars themselves.
You can have a clean energy future
where we're recycling metals and minerals
from batteries that store
wind and solar energy
into electric cars
that are then re-recycled back out
into other forms of storage and batteries.
- Interesting, okay, wow, yeah,
that is like an optimistic
view of batteries
'cause it just feels so finite
but if the lifespan is
dramatically higher,
that becomes a much more useful
and less resource-intensive proposition.
- There's also one more possibility,
and I think the people will call me
a little bit high in the sky here
but I'm okay with that.
I think it's possible
that it may not just be
about fixing the problem with cars,
but also about fixing the problem of cars.
There's a high-tech version of this
where self-driving cars,
there's some research and speculation
that they might reduce the amount of cars
that we're using in total.
There's also a lower-tech version of this
where we just invest
more in public transport.
That might sound unsexy but
it really does seem to me
like the most promising option.
I think also if you zoom out for a second
and think about why we
care about climate change,
yes, we care about animals
and we care about the planet itself,
but we also care a lot
about human suffering.
One of the reasons why so many people
care about climate change
is because it will cause human suffering,
it already is.
And so if you take this story
and you look at the human
suffering caused by mining
and you then say, oh,
we're not gonna try
and solve this problem,
we're just, what, gonna let
more climate change happen?
We have to solve these
things at the same time
because both will hurt
more people, basically.
- Yeah, that's a really good point.
I think if there's two major takeaways
that I take from your research into this
is like, number one,
a greener future is not inherently
a cleaner, more idealistic, happy future,
it's just a less CO2 future,
which is like, again, obvious,
it's so obvious when you say it like that
and make that differentiation,
but I had those so deeply bound together.
But I think the more important idea
is like even though I
have a pessimistic view
of great power rivalry,
there's not an option here.
Like, there's no scenario in
which throwing up my hands
and being like the world is effed
is gonna do anything.
And in fact it's the easier
way out in a lot of ways.
And so it's good to know that
there is real work being done
to try to solve this
and that it's not just bound
to go down the same route.
- In my mind, this story
isn't a cleaner future
is just as bad.
It's a cleaner future is a cleaner future,
with problems that we still have to solve.
(gentle music)